[Music]
welcome welcome back to this special
edition of Hannity scandals plaguing the
Democrats for months this program has
been shining a light on one particularly
damning scandal involving the Clintons
and the very sketchy sale of uranium one
last night the hills John Solomon
released a brand-new report detailing
that now even Democratic Senator Dianne
Feinstein is seeking access to an
informant who helped the FBI investigate
a bribery case surrounding that Russian
state energy company but Hillary Clinton
wants you to think this scandal it's
much to do about nothing take a look at
this
the Iranian one story has been debunked
countless times by members of the press
by independent experts it is nothing but
a you know a false charge that the Trump
administration is trying to drum up this
is such an abuse of power and it goes
right at the rule of law if they send a
signal that we're gonna be like some
dictatorship some authoritarian regime
where political opponents are going to
be unfairly fraudulently investigated
that rips at the fabric of the contract
we have that we can trust our justice
system in a radio interview early today
Hillary Clinton reiterated those
comments and even call the uranium one
scandal a quote political stunt joining
us now with reaction is the author of
Clinton cash from the Government
Accountability Institute
Peter Schweitzer good evening Peter you
know major great to see you good to see
you is well when your book first came
out in 2015 you know did you ever wonder
why in 2015 there wasn't an automatic
investigation you know by Congress by
the FBI by the Justice Department and
because Peter when I read that book you
recovered it here I can
herded on justice I mean it was
explosive your facts were uncontroverted
and yet Hillary Clinton says you know it
was a false charge it was you know it
was controverted by you know press
reports I mean what was what is she
talking about yeah it's certainly not
the way that I recall it look you know
the book came out in April of 2015 the
uranium one story we shared before the
book came public with the investigative
unit at the New York Times they ran at
4,000 word front page peace confirming
the findings the hidden donations the
the the C feeis approval the Clintons
connections to this drama and really
after the book came out judge the FBI
did launch an investigation and they
felt there was enough compelling
evidence this has been widely reported
in The Wall Street Journal in other
places they felt there was enough
evidence to get the Department of
Justice to grant them subpoena powers
and they were turned down by the Obama
Justice Department so you know her
argument that this has been debunked it
hasn't been debunked all the debunkers
do judge is they changed the timeline or
they exclude facts and they say the fact
pattern doesn't work because they've
excluded certain facts and what I've
said from the beginning you and I have
talked about it you're a seasoned
prosecutor is look you just need to
investigate and find out what happened
and then you can figure out what crimes
if any have been committed and that's
all we're calling for you know Peter I I
have to commend you because but for you
we wouldn't know about this and you know
on my show justice one of the things
that I did was I talked about the fact
that uranium is an essential ingredient
for Molly 99 which the law in this
country requires that you know we make
in this country that we are now shipping
uranium out to other countries and then
paying for it it's an essential
ingredient for nuclear medicine for
medical isotopes it now makes sense to
me that you know the Russians were in
such a rush to buy it but what do you
think is going to happen if this
witness who was gagged and now Diane
Feinstein wants to hear from this FBI
informant and is now ungag what do you
think we're gonna hear from him well I
have to say up front I have not met him
I don't know him
but what I understand by looking at
legal documents involved in his case
this guy was an insider's insider he was
being paid by the Russian company
$50,000 a month to serve as a lobbyist
and in the legal filings what you find
is his job was to basically carry the
flag for this entity in Washington DC
and that job included setting up
meetings with high-ranking
administration officials this would have
been the Obama administration people on
Capitol Hill and other elite influence
you know makers so he was working at a
very very high level and what has leaked
out seems to indicate he's got a lot of
information that relates specifically to
uranium one so it's going to be very
exciting and I think it's important to
point out judge also remember we already
have a foreign government official
saying that involving uranium one that
that he and his fellow government
employees were extorted by the Clintons
then-senator Hillary Clinton this comes
from the Kazakh head of their atomic
agency saying that Senator Clinton
refused to meet with Kazakh officials
unless and until they granted uranium
concessions to Frank Giustra who ended
up giving you no more than a hundred
million dollars to the Clinton
Foundation so we've got that testimony
we've got this new witness coming out
it's going to get very interesting here
in the weeks ahead Peter
were you ever afraid for your life as
you were investigating this as you as
you were writing the book well I'll just
say this judge in general terms you know
we do take and have taken security
precautions we do face in our
organization cyber challenges on a
regular basis you know this is important
stuff and I think the more public it is
the better it is for everybody who's
investigating it whether that's the
informant or
whether that's other journalists who
were pursuing this story do you think
that ultimately there will be justice in
this case you know look I think there
should be and I think right now I think
we take this step by step and I remember
you and I sat down in New York and had
lunch and you taught walked me through
the the process of prosecution it's a
step by step first thing we need to do
is gather all the information without
having one subpoena without having
looked at any of Hillary's emails while
not looking at any personal
communications we already have the
transference of money that money being
hidden not publicized by the Clintons
that they received this money at the
time the deal was being approved and we
have a witness this foreign senior
government official and we now have this
other informant that's a lot of evidence
without one subpoena without any
investigatory powers being used so you
know let's gather all the information
and found out what happens all right
Peter thanks so much